at 82 few could match his stamina but
uncle Wang is driven by profound sense
of responsibility caught between water
cannon and tear gas on one side and
petrol bombs on the other he doesn't shy
away instead he dashes towards the
frontlines from morning until night
weekend after weekend to protect those
he says of fighting for the Hong Kong
he's lived in all of his life I've
enjoyed years of democracy in Hong Kong
but we're living in a new era the world
has changed dramatically in the last few
months why are so many young people
being assaulted by the police police
should be protecting people uncool Wong
is a member of the community group
protect the children led by Pastor Roy
Chan they put themselves between the
police and protesters guiding the young
people they aim to shield away from the
crime but as every passing week grows
more violence the stakes get a little
bit higher
why I don't fear death not when the
children are out here fighting for
democracy and risking their own lives
it's the responsibility of elderly
people like me to come out and protect
them if I fear death I wouldn't be here
as tempers boil over uncle Wang pushes
for calm but weeks of unrest have taken
their toll on both sides as a passionate
pro-democracy advocate uncle Wang
pleased with police not to hurt
protesters if they're arrested and
charged with rioting they face up to 10
years in prison the children just want
to fight for democracy freedom and human
rights the core values of Hong Kong and
to prevent Hong Kong from becoming just
another Chinese city if we can help the
young people to win the movement I will
be very happy I will be able to die
without regret uncle Wang says he'll
keep returning to the streets as long as
the protests continue one man and his
walking stick now an icon of the
movement